[Applause]
ross and i want to play a game and win
some money for the audience
all right then i guess that means yes
um let's do this as you can see we have
teamed up with kellogg's for this very
special segment now here's how the game
works our audience is divided into two
teams
team ross
that's a good-looking team
and team drew
i know
wow guys it's on barrymore oh it is on
rossi ross matthews
all right we're each going to reveal
something about ourselves and the other
person has to guess if it's surreal true
or unreal false for example i would say
i starred in a kellogg's commercial when
i was six years old and if you guessed
that was cereal you'd be right mm-hmm
that's right that's so crazy i'm proud
that i'm still working with kellogg's 40
years later
i know
i feel really lucky i'm serious i'm not
going to take that for granted all right
now for every answer we guess correctly
we get a point for our team and we get
to take a bite of kellogg's frosted mini
wheats they're my favorite because they
have all the fiber vitamins and minerals
i love raisin bran too though all right
whoever gets the most points will win um
50 gift cards for their entire team
let's play surreal or unreal yes
[Applause]
yes giving away money all right and we
want our teams to help us out so you all
have flower poles right now so if you
think our statement is true
join in hold up the green flower but if
you think we're lying hold up the red
flower you got it all right let's get
started i'm up first here is my first
one okay
i once accidentally called elizabeth
taylor dame edna
okay is that surreal or unreal
looks like a lot of people think you did
i feel like i want to go with the
audience on this everybody thinks that
you did so i'm going to say cereal
i'm right you're right yeah yeah this is
a point for kindred
great
you get to have a bite of cyril and le
please let me please explain very
quickly you know i didn't know i was
going to interview dame elizabeth taylor
and they said you have to call her dame
and i was like oh like dame edna and
then when i walked in i just said dame
edna elizabeth taylor and it went
downhill from there so
sorry
all right i spent a week at the real
grey gardens house before i made the
movie grey gardens
cereal or unreal what do you guys think
yeah mostly green out there so i'm gonna
say surreal
yes yeah
we get a point i did it was the coolest
thing ever to uh sleep
uh with jessica lange at the real great
gardens and we rehearsed the whole movie
in the house for a week with our
director michael soucy wow i know oh
yeah that was very cool well we are tied
one to one all right anybody's game
here's my next one
drew i speak three languages fluently
is that serial or unreal
wow um
okay for starters how dare all of you
i'm gonna go with the audience on this
one not because i don't love you rossi
but i mean three languages that's hard
unreal
you know
next time maybe they should put two
languages i
you know i was rooting for half of you i
was
yeah i don't uh speak three languages
i'm working on that one though working
on that one
steven spielberg made me wait until i
was 10 years old to pierce my ears
cereal or unreal
why do i feel like that
i'm gonna say that's surreal you got it
yes
[Applause]
all right just the last question when i
was 14 and i got my first apartment
frosted mini wheats were basically all i
ate
cereal or unreal
i think that's surreal
yes
that is when i named them fmws and i
have to say i really have a deep
affinity for it it makes me feel very
comforted and it's absolutely delicious
and nutritious agreed agreed all right
team ross oh is the winner
no but come on drew
i mean my team's all gonna win but what
about everybody else
everybody's gonna win today
our entire studio audience is going home
with 50 gift cards each and every one of
you please spend it and think of us and
kellogg's when you do and do something
that makes yourselves happy
and thank you for coming here today and
playing this game with us and
ross i will hang with you over a bowl of
cereal any day
and sharing a bowl of kellogg's raisin
bran or frosted mini wheats with a
friend is such a fun way to kick off
your morning with joy laughter and it
helps fuel your day with fiber
[Music]